normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government all
right ladies and gentlemen uh I want to
play this video for you of Nikki Haley
and explain to you why it is that you
must vote for Donald Trump and why it is
this woman should never be any allowed
anywhere near the seats of power reclaim
the net says Nikki Haley says if she's
made president every social media user
will be verified by their name for
national security purposes and we will
uh we'll play that video for
you when I get into office the first
thing we have to do social media
accounts social media companies they
have to show America their algorithms
let us see why they're pushing what
they're pushing okay that I like but
carry on the second thing is every
person on social media should be
verified by their name that's first of
all it's a national security threat when
you do that all of a sudden people have
to stand by what they say and it gets
rid of the Russian Bots the Iranian Bots
and the Chinese Bots and then you're
going to get some civility when people
know their name is next to what they say
accountability and they know their
pastor and their family members going to
see it it's going to help our kids and
it's going to help our country oh the
funny thing about that is uh she's
completely wrong uh this country is
built on Anonymous pamphlet and writing
and uh Benjamin Franklin and Thomas
Jefferson and many others so uh what
she's doing is she's taking things that
Elon Musk has pointed out which are good
ideas the option to be verified and the
choice to interact with those who are
and turning it into the Govern will
force you to do it and then she
immediately goes first of all she's like
everyone needs to have their name
attached to their social security or to
their social networking first of all
it's a national security threat like
yeah that would be a national security
threat if you forced everyone to put
their name on their social no but but
but you get the point is she inverted it
she didn't mean it to sound like that
the reason she's calling it a national
security threat that Anonymous accounts
is because that is their hard you can't
stop us we don't need a vote
justification we are going to send a
national security letter to to X at and
force them to do it to Facebook etc etc
they're going to make you do it the
purpose of mindes one of the main tenets
of mindes is that Anonymous social
networking is is a human right in my
opinion I don't know if Bill's actually
come out and literally said that social
media company I found it in 2011 with
Bill opman it's you have to be able to I
didn't think about it so deeply before
but it's exactly like you said man um
silence do good was Benjamin Franklin's
first pen name he couldn't get published
in his brother's paper when he was like
14 so he made some fake middle-aged lady
and then he started getting Lish and of
course uh Poor Richard's Almanac he was
a guy named poor Richard and he would
seed like revolutionary content into the
populace cuz he always his whole life he
probably wanted to revolt against the
king but he wasn't able if he said out
loud they would have cut his head off so
he had to use a pen name and if the same
thing in modern day if it becomes
tyranical especially when there are
people who feel like their anonymity
allows them to operate in society
because their views are not permitted I
mean to to confront you'd have to start
really unpacking what hate speech is in
America if you really wanted to take
away
Anonymous speech online and where where
the boundaries of free speech are and
and that's what I think you know I I'm
not totally against her justification of
like if you had to put your name by
everything you said maybe you would
operate differently maybe that's good
but there are people who write you know
under pen names because they fear that
they'll be targeted by a progressive
attorney general who might go after
their job or whatever else because they
believe something that's not popular it
starts to be this thing where like I
just wonder what box we're opening and
I'm not against the idea of
accountability online but uh at what
cost and what are we protecting and it's
kind of ironic because Nikki Haley rails
against China just one of the many
countries she probably wants to go to
war with but at the same time I mean
this this is the exact same type of
police state that China is rightfully
criticize for so this is something that
she wants to introduce I mean it's like
she is on the wrong side of basically
every single issue which is almost
impressive she's like impressive batting
average for just like the George Bush
Republicans who basically killed the
party for an entire generation we should
just make it so that in order to pass a
bill the person who is proposing it has
to uh uh enter Tri uh legislation by
combat M so to literally Force bne mull
is all getting all the stuff through
you've got you've got to carry the the
the the the bill pass through the gaun
Gladiators then they all the congressman
they all have paddles and they they the
butt un ironically enter in a new golden
age for America have you guys seen all
those studies where they they look at
how high testosterone and like gym
attendance correlates with right-wing
views we studied this yeah it's amazing
within 24 hours you'll feel the right
wing seeping into you start to work out
Ian Ian lifted the barbell one time and
then dropped it and then started praying
I just I become happy with myself when
I'm physically healthy and that's part
of like I maybe I want to conserve my
life and my surroundings because I
appreciate them more when I'm physically
yeah I think that's true I think it does
give you uh it gives you a sense of
value and purpose which changes your how
you approach the world which is is very
interesting I guess what also that also
get rid of of all the octogenarians that
we have in Congress as well true they
couldn't keep up they're not the age
categories it's like 72 to 78 they all
fight they all are way
Mullins I fight mull that me so funny uh
the other thing that stood out to me is
that she said this is the first thing I
do in office and I guess my question to
you guys would be what would you want
whoever gets elected to do what the
first what should be the first thing
they do when they get to office ring
people that's a great question something
secretive that is big and changes a lot
of stuff um but what she said about all
these social networks free their code I
don't agree with anymore I think we
start with Tik Tok because it's a
foreign company and proof of concept if
they want to operate on us Shore they
have to free their software code their
algorithms and then if that turns out
that it's really great for society then
we can use that as a castus belly to
cause meta to open up their code yeah
let me tell you so we have we have
social media people who work here at
timcast and we have the the semi
Unwritten rules of fa social media
platforms when posting and Tik Tok is
the most insanely restrictive mhm
absolutely
face so YouTube surprisingly the least
well I I should pause Rumble is the
least ax and Rumble are like you know
basically anything goes just you're
you're good to go and we we love that
YouTube is actually one of the least
restrictive though they are fairly
restrictive yeah and it's it's crazy cuz
I I mean I've got the Blaze's YouTube
channel suspended for an entire week
because I'm I'm not going to say what I
said about uh the Elliot page I'll
actually use the the name so I don't
want to get your your page suspended
either but um yeah that happened on
YouTube but it was for something that I
mean I feel like YouTube's
more selective about than something like
Facebook which yeah fa uh YouTube
actually does in some circumstances look
at context Facebook absolutely does not
and I'm not I'm not trying to defend
YouTube I think YouTube censorship is a
problem but Facebook is insanely bad and
Tik Tok is substantially worse it feels
like Facebook relies a lot more on AI
than than than alphabet and there's like
no legitimate appeals process it takes
forever whereas with YouTube we actually
have like reps we can contact at a
certain level on YouTube there's people
who will work with you Facebook doesn't
care yeah they don't they don't want you
to appeal because they've made a
decision and it's it's crazy like my
channel uh my page on on uh Facebook got
demonetized once for for lies uh an
organization claimed that one of my
videos was fake news and so it triggered
a
demonetization and my my my video that I
put up was 100% factually correct I
reached out to the organization and I
said my video is correct and they said
no it's not here's your headline and I
said the headline is a question and the
first sentence of the video is rejecting
the claims made by people who are
asserting this and they were like oh we
didn't actually watch it so a third
party flagged me to Facebook and got my
money turned off that's insane that's
what Facebook does it's not even about
their internal teams it's about them
letting leftist Progressive activists
and government agents and I got to
wonder with this election Integrity
partnership partnership stuff going on
I'm I'm wondering if you know maybe we
should reach out to members of Congress
who are working on this and the people
we know who are working on it and ask
them about what Facebook is doing with
the pointer Institute and the and the or
and and the power they give to third
parties to remove content they don't
like but see that's why that's why the
left always wins and they're going to
keep winning I work with a ton of
right-wing conservative nonprofits I
mean people people like tpusa we would
never think hang on there's this huge
company that has control of information
I should petition them so that I'm in
charge of what people are allowed to
post like that would never enter into
like 99% of conservatives Minds the left
not only think this but they actually
put it into action and they insert
themselves into roles of power very
effectively unless unless the subject is
Israel yes unless then all of a sudden
it's like everybody's just like there's
then it's like the me yeah right then
it's just I don't know what's going on
that's the fascist bent in people when
they're like we got to use the private
companies to control society and they'll
use it through legislation or through
funding through legislation yeah I don't
like when that happens I kind of want to
answer your your question about what I
would do if I became president Ro I
don't have an answer you guys what would
you do well I I I like this tweet that V
put out the other day day I don't know
if he said it would be day one but I
think it should be day one immediately
fire half of uh like the the DC
bureaucrats or the civil servants just
you know transfer them I'm good with
firing them I think like if if it
automatically there's half of them I
mean obviously we could talk about the
economic comp uh I guess implications of
that many people being out of a out of a
job but if it's like if the federal
government is so huge where we actually
need to talk about The Economic
Consequences of that many civil servants
losing their jobs then that's a problem
in and of itself he was saying layoffs
because that bypasses the restrictions
you can lay them off for budgetary
reasons and yes absolutely and uh I
would I would I would hope that
VI to the extent it is legally humanly
and economically possible maximizes
those layoffs there's no there's no you
know what it is so we were talking last
night about schools and I was saying
like abolish the doe and get rid of this
broken system we had Aaron mat on and he
was arguing that I'm an exception to the
rule I'm successful not everyone can do
that and my argument is if you don't
think or if you think that there is no
way to replicate in you know my success
in other people then what's the point of
school if School can't create a path
toward success for people to be then
what's the point of doing it and uh my
you know his his his attitude was
basically there's a lot of good teachers
who are in these schools and this is my
point the government funds a project
hires a bunch of people and then says
okay this doesn't work but we can't stop
it now because we're addicted to it we
are economically addicted to this
industry if we stop funding schools
we're going to have hundreds of
thousands of people out of work we can't
have it the economy would collapse also
because we didn't allow for any
competition I mean there are private
schools there are home schools things
like that but obviously predominantly
most people's money are tied up in their
taxes which then go to their public
school so they rely on them I mean
education in America is ultimately a
failing business so it should
close falsely kept alive and what Ron
Paul said and it was funny because when
we had Ron on the show I mentioned this
to him and he was like did I say that he
said of the uh war in a I think it was
Afghanistan they're saying we can't just
withdraw because it will cause a bunch
of problems but as a doctor I know if
you prescribe the wrong medication and
it is causing problems you stop the
medication there's there's no excuse for
saying we have to just keep doing it we
are addicted to these government
programs and the fear is oh but if we
terminate we're going to lose all these
jobs don't know don't care that was and
especially with education we can see the
outcomes right test scores are going
down I mean some of the places that have
the highest per student funding have the
worst results and I I'm someone who's
very pro- homeschooling and the response
is always like oh your kids aren't going
to be able to read you're not qualified
it's like I mean we see what the actual
results are from kids who are in public
schools public schools that are failing
them it's really hard for it to be worse
actual Justice Warrior Sean he did a
video where I think places in Baltimore
like there's a a lot of schools where
literally 0% like well or Oregon just
did away with their graduation
requirements and they're saying there
are learning losses because of coid but
also that means your system is pretty
weak that exactly three years could I
mean students really suffered during Co
for a lot of reasons but it also means
that like there was absolutely no
effective Effectiveness in online
schooling or anything else the teachers
that were tasked with having to educate
kids remotely couldn't do it this means
that our system is not adap this is not
this is not proof that you guys are
successful and I think to Tim's uh
medicine metaphor you know Ron Paul's
Ron Paul uh you know if they're saying
this is the thing you take to fix it you
go to public school the thing is doctors
will then say oh you're having side
effects from the medication I gave you
instead of stopping it they'll say take
five others take this other one take
this other one which is why you know we
get Universal preschool and we get all
these other programs that the government
is saying we're not effective but we're
going to continue to fund ourselves
until we figure out a way to keep this
failing system up and that's that's a
disservice to students and their parents
if you gave them I mean this is why I
love school choice if you gave them the
opportunity to spend their monies in a
way that better suited their children's
need because there's no way bureaucrats
in Washington know children better than
their own parents they would probably be
more effective well that's the problem
though the the the Department of
Education and the public school system
it exists to benefit teachers to benefit
administrators it's not actually to the
benefit of the students and much
definitely not the benefit of the
parents I think one of the things you
said um Hannah clir exactly that that is
pretty profound is that the the problem
that this this school the education
system the Department of Education is
that there's no they have a monopoly
there's no real viable op option if it
does shut down like there's not another
system where people can just go get jobs
there and and bring their kids over
there and there should be because the
Monopoly government monopolies are just
as dangerous as private sector
monopolies this is this is what I saw in
Venezuela when you went to go buy a cell
phone there were like six to eight
stations I I go to T-Mobile in the
United States I walk in there's a guy
and he's like how can I help you I I
want a phone he's like okay he gets his
his tablet out and he's like which phone
do you want he starts typing it all in
here your number and okay it's going to
cost this I swiped the card it's kind of
annoying and then you're done in
Venezuela you had they had to create
fake jobs for the sake of propping up
their fake economy which didn't work
obviously so they're mandated to have a
person who gets the phone a person who
asks you what kind of phone you want a
person who deals with your phone plan a
person takes the money a person who
writes down the bill like you walk in
you say they say how can I help you I
would like to buy a new phone okay let
me F this form for you here you go and
go wait in that line then you go wait
another L there's another person there
and which phone would you like to buy
okay F this form and then go wait over
here then a guy takes the form from you
then he says okay now go wait over there
then so it's it's it's insane that's
what we're doing right now in this
country and and I think you made a good
point I think you you brought this up
that the government created a monopoly
on schools by mass funding it this is
what happens when the government
guarantees the income there's it's it's
almost impossible to compete but then
you'll see things like FedEx ups and the
Postal Service clearly people don't like
using the postal service for whatever
reason right and you get you get private
schools you get home schools you get
co-ops people do have Innovation
especially when they see that the system
is broken but it makes me wonder you
know you'll have student you teachers
who are promised if you if you work in a
public school for X number of years
we'll pay off your student loan debt
which we have also given you because
we're the government and we're trying to
help you uh and I would wonder if it
would be more interesting to see those
people go off and start you know monor
schools in more places or explore you
know different opportunities with the
degree that they have I think good
teachers are really valuable it's not to
shame all of them but the government
just wants you to stay in its broken
system and it's willing to take you down
with it if you're a teacher and I think
you're right a good teacher a competent
teacher is going to flourish even
without the public school and the
teachers un and safety net and we see
that with Charter Schools and private
schools and there are even I guess
industrious teachers who are creating
their own homes school curriculums that
could be applied to different homeschool
pods like there there there's there's a
desperate need for teachers who are
competent but I don't think we do those
teachers any any service by subsidizing
the incompetent on and the government
doesn't reward teachers entrepreneurship
it just beats them back into submission
as much as they can until they you know
eventually establish something which is
not good thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net